round of applause for Maurice jones-drew
please okay I appreciate it then also
for Roger Staubach as he leaves after
getting three of ten behind Kurt Warner
said to me he should have had at least
five I know I mean he's a gamer I mean
that's how you become a hall-of-famer
right spirit and he also called art my
good friend up Bailey who's in the
audience right here I have not seen
Bailey since he helped time my 40-yard
dash last year at the combine part here
part-and-parcel looking as great as ever
thanks to the folks at st. Jude
Children's Research Hospital and he
called Bailey up onstage and told Bailey
that if he missed the last one he would
give him $10 he pulled it well he won't
spend the $10 because the $10 that Roger
Staubach took out of his wallet he then
autographed for Bailey so there's
there's two autographs on that from the
Secretary of the Treasury and Roger Sava
the Secretary of the Navy and the
Secretary of of the Treasury so thanks
again Roger great to see you Bailey and
now good to see you Maurice jones-drew
somebody doing well I'm uh it's funny
that this helmets up here can I tell you
a quick story please go for it the buy
some devices helmets so was it three or
four years ago I want to say we were at
a four years ago we were at Stanford
kind of a sports psychology deal and the
vises helmet was there and I took my
youngest son with me who will be there
tonight for our game night okay but I
took him from school without telling
anyone I just told him to said come with
me so the police were looking for me
that was one issue fact fact that the
police were called because my son wasn't
at school it'll get better
so my wife is blowing my phone up and
we're sitting down and I'm sitting we're
talking about this helmet and I had an
opportunity I think invest in the
company right it was an opportunity and
I just didn't do it and I'm just not
smart well I mean it sounds like your
day was filled with bad decision it's
like bad off with a bad day it's just a
bad decision day for Maurice jones-drew
yes you didn't call the school to say
you're not bringing your son there I
didn't know we had to do that you know
but you did you know I just I was like
hey I was taking over schools like you
know what just come with me I got to go
thing will have a tell your wife you
were doing was your hair good at least
was it a bad hair day do no hair was
phenomena okay I cut that night but yeah
so your haircut yeah here well you want
that hot by like the Raiders good so
you're you mentioned the game night
we're gonna be doing the game day game
night survey a pictionary crazy type
game night night half-hour show live on
the NFL Network tonight at six o'clock
if you're at the experience to come on
out I'm hosting a bunch of stuff you're
also part of the eight and a half hour
pregame show on the NFL Network that
started five minutes ago all fall in
Super Sunday and then also you're
calling the game for the Rams yeah
that's gonna be a little nerve-wracking
but are you calling the game would be
great how the Rams look to you this week
yeah you know it's the first person if
you have you not eyeball how good
haven't I see him huh what are you
hearing about oh I've been hearing a lot
I mean I know they had a great practice
they're they're really dialed in I've
talked to a couple of players they're
excited about this opportunity right
because again you're talking about a
team three years ago that everyone
thought was we talked about this on air
the last time it was a time when we were
all on the plane like who where are we
gonna go from here and so yeah that was
the Thursday night game blowout three
days after they fired Jeff Fisher yep
Jared Goff had still yet to win a game
as the starter was his fifth start as a
starter and there wasn't a single person
on that plane that thought there were 37
games removed from the Super Bowl or
that in a year in two years time any
team that had just fired their coach was
trying to replicate whatever the Rams
were cooking right nobody thought that
would be possible on that plane and so
you know to kind of call the journey
over the last couple of years to see
those guys and then you talk to them got
a chance to reach out to a couple
coaches and then there's all they're
just enjoying the moment really but they
know that it's a tough task ahead and
we're gonna battle we're gonna do this
pointing is the Patriot fan we're gonna
battle it's on I think it's gonna be fun
I think it will be too it's girly hurt
or not no he's not hurt and then what
happened man similar to the devices
story yeah
he's had a bad day right it's just I
think sometimes he's wake up on the
wrong side of the bed I've had bad games
there was a game we played on Monday
night against the Baltimore Ravens where
I fumbled four times didn't scored
fumbled right before I got in the
endzone you just have bad days and so
just so happened that his was in the NFC
Championship game well I think if it's
just gonna work to his benefit because
I'm seeing he's on Twitter he's active
this oh yes okay and he retweeted
somebody talking about his performance
against the Cowboys and he goes oh
that's right I had a hundred yards
against the Cowboys I forgot so and I
assume that I read the tweet in that
tone of voice and that was a tone of
voice that Ibrahim nted yes and I think
again you know we were such a our
society we like to live in the moment
the last thing we saw that's why the
call the non call has been so big and
all those things but let's remember he
got hurt week one and all those big
games that he had throughout the season
until the last couple weeks I mean he
was doing it on the same knee that
everyone's really thinking that he's
banged up on so you know the 200-yard
game against Denver and the three
touchdown games that he was having and
all it was all be the big game against
Detroit you know so he he's a very
capable player to make plays and I think
they'll utilize him Maurice jones-drew
here on the Rich Eisen show what about
the idea that they need to have a game
like that from O'Reilly to win well when
Gurley gets going that offense is
unstoppable because now the play-action
pass opens up Jarrod golf's more
comfortable the receivers are seeing
simple coverages you need those type of
games it helps that offens better helps
a team better because again he's one of
the vocal leaders on the team but I also
think when Todd's having fun you see
that it kind of takes a lot of the
pressure off where when you saw the
Saints he wasn't having a good time they
were showing him like stretching on the
sidelines his face way it was just you
could see the kind of the other players
feed off that and so when Todd smiling
talking trash to the cameras all those
things they're normally doing a really
good job and they're having a good time
okay so Rams own two against the NFC
Championship game part of participants
from this year in last year okay they
were all one two against the Eagles and
the own one against the Eagles and only
one against the the Saints they were on
one they want to know against the Chiefs
that's what I'm trying to say right so
they played against the Eagles a lot of
folks thought
should have been in the NFC Championship
game we talked to their own won against
the Saints whose fan base thinks they
should be in the Superbowl and there
they beat the Chiefs who a lot of folks
think and we got Travis Kelce coming on
in the third hour they kind of got hosed
by the the the rules on overtime
yeah the toss I understand that so well
or if you win the toss you've got a
score yes right which obviously the
Saints did not do are the Patriots the
best team that the Rams have faced this
year I would say they're talented wise I
think they're the best team Thanks
probably the Saints are the Eagles the
Eagles don't get enough credit for the
talent that they had I know they had a
lot of injuries but like Al Shean
Jeffery golden Tam and they put they
brought together a nice group it would
have to be the same so I think top to
bottom the Saints are probably one of
the most talented team to the league but
the thing that you know you're going
against the greatest of all time to go
and that's the difference Tom Brady's
seen everything Bilbo's we've seen
everything they played against Wade
Phillips a ton they've had little
success Wade has had a little success I
think the Patriots have had more and
that's a concern but again you know just
like last year the Eagles had two guys
that won
you know Super Bowls with the Patriots
or played for the Patriots just like the
Rams do Brandon cooks and to keep to
leave they're gonna play a big role in
this game because those are guys that
you pick their brain last week on what
Tom Brady likes to do what is it's
called why do they like to do this and
then vice versa for McVeigh like what
why they run this type of coverage is
what do you think they're gonna try to
do with a keep to leave then you can
game plan and scheme around that Maurice
jones-drew here on the Rich Eisen show
here's what I think is that is the key
here because we could talk about 50
million different things I'm sure you
have all week on NFL Network and we
could do it here if we had the time but
I think it comes down to this with
McVeigh and Belichick and McDaniels and
Wade Phillips you've got some terrific
minds operating here right terrific
top and they're at the tops of their
games right now and you've got Brady one
of the greatest executors of a game plan
ever in any sport and you got golf where
the setup with McVeigh
in his helmet until fifteen seconds to
go is gonna be key it's here the key is
who's going to disrupt the best will the
Patriots be able to disrupt golf by
disguising their coverage confusing him
turning him into the golf that second
guesses that doesn't hit the back foot
and rip it or will sue and Donald come
up the middle on Brady and disrupt the
one thing that Brady does which is
timing not getting sacked which he is
yet to be sacked this postseason really
I don't know that's that that's why you
come on the show yeah that's a matter of
fact my husband only one quarterback
who's gone through an entire postseason
from beginning to winning a Super Bowl
or playing in the Super Bowl and never
been set once and that was Brady before
so here he is now again has been hasn't
been sacked so who's going to disrupt
the most so
yeah I'll say that's the most important
thing for the Rams is to start fast and
getting their tempo when they get in
tempo they haven't been stopped I think
there's a stat where they're one of the
top three teams in the league in the
two-minute situations at half the score
points and at the end of the game to
score points and that's important
because most of these games come down to
the last two minutes or the Super Bowls
come down to the last two minutes of the
game whoever has the ball so for me is
if they can get fast and getting to that
no huddle offense where they can move
down the field that's what they did
against the Saints that's how they're
able to come back yeah well that's what
the Falcons did against the Patriots
with all due respect to the Atlanta
folks who are here and then so you got
to play all four no disrespect to you
know the Falcons fans but they weren't
they're not think they had the Rams
ability with the weapons new day had
Julio don't be wrong with one of the
greatest catches in the history of the
game that we'd be talking about today if
they want it exactly right okay then and
hold on man and Devonta Freeman and
Tevin call I mean special and not Ryan
Ryan DP has more expect more experience
going into that game in golf does I
don't want to get caught in this
wormhole but but I just think that you
know this team they've been through a
lot throughout this season and last
season right the obviously the Falcons
beat them last year and they still have
a lot of you know things that they feel
they should be able to do so for me it's
more of
just getting back to what being you
don't force don't allow Bill Belichick
to change you like so many guys I think
Reggie Bush said it you should go out
with two backs well they never put do
back to the field so why would you do
that be you and do the best place that
you can do and execute your plays to the
best year ability and then see what
happens with the way the ball I would I
would rather lose being the Los Angeles
Rams of 2018 than trying to be something
else there's no question though that
Belichick and Brian Flores on defense is
going to tell these disguised the
defense to the last second they won't
commit until the last second yeah but
that helmet turned off on his head in
the Superbowl and see what's what
well I could tell you right away what
they're gonna do they're gonna play
cover 0 which is all-out blitz with no
safety help they're gonna try to get the
ball to get Jerry to think faster and
they're gonna play a lot of man coverage
they'll probably put Stephon Gilmore on
Robert woods and then double-team
Brandon cooks and then they'll allow
Josh Reynolds to do some things in those
tight ends and make plays on one-on-one
but you don't have to make tight you
know good throws into tight window so
McVeigh knows it too what's the gonna be
the counter then or did you don't care
it's just someone has to you someone's
gonna have to win you know at the end
the day you know I think I'm always
name-dropping our guys when Mike Robb
said it's Jimmy and Joe is not X and O's
that's what it comes down to super or
your players better than theirs at the
end of the day and you think the Rams
players are better looking at Brockman
and a better roster I'd have to say it
he said it CG Anderson student such a
difference make I mean rosters don't win
super good Malcolm Branagh been able to
do what CG Anderson is doing right now I
think Malcolm's a different running back
CJ is too yeah not even what he's done
on the field is what he brings off the
field like that veteran leadership you
know playing for different teams seeing
different things being cut and going
through adversity where he's hoping tide
out with some of that right now
obviously you know people are saying are
you hurt what's going on what's wrong
those type of deals but then also see
Anderson's are really good running back
and he's a phenomenal pass blocker and
Malcolm Brown was coming into that this
year before he got hurt I just I want to
see how they utilize both of those guys
if they would come back next year you
ready to call Super Bowl
I'm excited yeah I'm about to do a lot
of studying tonight
sounds like your your your good I mean
what's what do you study I want to make
sure when I go on with you before Sunday
that I'm ready and then I want to make
sure I call the game the right way so
this is you know so I mean I've never
been to this role for take it like like
that I've never I've never played in
this game so I want to make sure that I
give I'm but you've been here with the
NFL Network before right yeah but I've
never called the game it's a big deal I
know it is not to get you nervous and I
sleep too I went to bed early last I was
in bed at 11:30 last night Wow
cuz I wanted to make sure I was at my
best to no hooting with the owls no no
no not maybe tonight no don't do that
though all right kids don't do that okay
but no I'm gonna get I'm gonna kind of
dive in a little bit and then I'll
really get in tomorrow and be ready for
Sunday I'm excited for you I appreciate
that
really really AM you've been great all
playoff long all season long coming on
the show coming here again this
back-to-back Fridays for I love it I
know so
come don't don't forget we wager here
Maurice there's no such thing you keep
staring him down anyway here's the deal
he's afraid because I correctly
predicted the night's game yes worried
that I you know I got a little Oh what
you were actually you were wrong you say
they're gonna win by 20 and they won by
like 40 so and that's close have a great
one man I appreciate coming on Maurice
jones-drew everybody right here on the
show yes Charles Watson still to come
same with calamari it's an hour too
filled with Heisman Trophy winners when
we come back we will catch up and
whatever else is going on in the rest of
the world and there's a lot there's a
lot that's coming up here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience